you can make the school of life a
helpful part of your life in so many
ways the easiest and certainly the
cheapest is to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and our online book The Book of
Life you can also browse our online
short where you can order our books and
a variety of other products but we also
have physical hubs around the world
London and Paris Melbourne and Amsterdam
Istanbul soul sell Paola and others and
here you can come in and do something
properly special and transformational
attend one of our classes over the last
five years with the help of leading
experts in a variety of fields we've
designed what we call our core
curriculum a set of just over 30 classes
around the key issues that we consider
most central in emotional life
especially in the area of relationships
and work in our classrooms you'll find a
warm collegiate atmosphere our tutors
are hand-picked for their friendliness
empathy or knowledge
we have plenty of interaction
discussions and properly
transformational experiences a day or
evening on one of our core classes
typically leads to astonishing insights
new friendships and some breakthroughs
you'll find our full list of core
curriculum classes on our website go
around the program slowly perhaps over a
year or more or do it all at once in a
short burst you'll even get a
certificate in EQ when you complete the
circuit a visit to a school of life
classroom will give you the tools for a
more self-aware effective and
intelligent life it should also be
immensely entertaining and interesting
as well
you